the peak Andrew is a psychological
phenomenon that occurs when people judge
an experience largely on how they felt
at its peak and its end there are two
reasons for this
[Music]
more emotionally intense events lead to
better memories than less intense events
so if you experience a drama the peak is
what's most moving and to the mind
that's the most Vivid mental snapshot
we have a better memory at the end of a
sequence a phenomenon known as recency
bias if you get to eat three different
desserts in a row the second dessert
forms a new memory that makes it harder
for you to recall the first and when
you've finished all three your brain
remembers the last one most clearly
however the rule does not always work
as we go into an experience our
expectations play a lead role if they
are initially not met our prediction
error can affect our perception of
what's about to come next including the
peak but for now let's assume that
everything goes according to plan
foreign
ER and your expectations are low then
the memory of your evening will be
formed by the peak and the end the dry
salad the bad music and the dirty
bathroom are long forgotten later you
might rate the experience as exceptional
but what if your expectations are not
met
if you go out to eat at an expensive
restaurant you can have high
expectations if the initial experience
doesn't meet them your mind decides that
the place isn't that good after all and
you'll see everything through an overly
critical lens the peak is discounted the
end outrageous and then the overall
experience is rated poorly
so if expectations are low the rule
works if they are high it's important
that they are met right at the start
evidence for the rule was established
through an experiment in which people
were subjected to an unpleasant
experience in two different ways
the first trial had people submerge a
hand in cold water for 60 seconds in a
second trial people put their hand in
the same cold water for the same amount
of time but then kept it there for
another 30 seconds during which the
temperature was raised by about 1 degree
celsius the subjects were then offered
the option of which of the two trials to
repeat and as it turns out they were
more willing to repeat the second trial
despite the prolonged exposure to the
cold water
Kahneman Frederickson Schreiber and
radelmeyer who conducted the study in
1993 concluded that people chose the
long trial simply because they liked the
memory of it better than the alternative
if you happen to run a restaurant and
manage to meet your customers
expectations you can create a wonderful
Peak finish with a fantastic end and
deliver an experience that's not only
excellent but will also be remembered as
such
now what do you think about the rule and
did you ever make your own Peak end
experience please share your thoughts
and what you remember from this video in
the comments below
foreign
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com